es brodelt in der coco union und spd
können sich bei der grundrente nicht
einigen und verschieben das für morgen
geplante spitzentreffen ende eine
irrfahrt das deutsche rettungsschiff
alanco die legt mit 88 flüchtlingen an
bord im süditalienischen trend an
grund randale im stadion beim
bundesliga-derby zwischen union berlin
und hertha bsc feiern fans pyrotechnik
aufs spielfeld mehrere menschen werden
verletzt
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zu einem kurzen
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem sonntag
norbert lehmann ist auch dabei für den
sport als schön oder am tor von mir eine
grundrente für langjährige
geringverdiener
eigentlich wollte die große koalition
morgen ihren monatelangen streit darüber
beilegen
doch das treffen der partei- und
koalitionsspitzen ist geplatzt nachdem
am wochenende immer mehr unionspolitiker
bedenken über den kompromiss äußerten
wurde das spitzentreffen verschoben aus
berlin daniel protzen viele in der spd
werden sich nach wie vor in guter
verhandlungsposition für zugeständnisse
der union damit die halbzeit bilanz
positiv ausfällt und die gruppe weiter
machen kann
der generalsekretär vor wenigen minuten
ich bin guter dinge dass wir eine
einigung hinbekommen wir sind jetzt sehr
weit gekommen in verhandlungen aber es
gibt jetzt noch diskussionsbedarf im
geteilt da müssen noch einzelheiten
geklärt werden und ich kann ein halb an
alle appellieren dass wir jetzt wirklich
schnell fertig werden
vor ein paar tagen hieß es ist ein
kompromiss erreicht der die aufstockung
der rente nicht allgemein von
bedürftigkeit sondern konkret vom
einkommen abhängig mache offen aber
blieben entscheidende details von denen
abhängt wie viele menschen am ende
profitieren und dadurch wie teuer es
wird
laute warnung vor ausufernden kosten zu
lasten künftiger generationen kamen
daraufhin aus der union von jens spahn
von verhandlungsführer hermann gröhe und
den jungen unionsabgeordneten
wir gehen von kosten von ca 3 milliarden
euro im jahr aus das sind bei zehn
jahren 30 milliarden euro die fehlen uns
für eine gute wirtschaftspolitik bei dem
aufbau einer guten infrastruktur oder
bei der bewältigung der digitalisierung
von daher finger weg von allem was über
den koalitionsvertrag hinausgehen so
wuchs der druck auf die unionsführung
stündlich am ende die verschiebung des
koalitionsausschusses schon zuvor eine
mahnung aus bayern
am ende braucht jede regierung geduld
und jede regierung muss doch am ende die
fähigkeit haben zu kompromissen zu
finden
es ist ein guter kompromiss sein es geht
hier nicht um der spd an bonus zu geben
wie manch einer meint aber man muss ja
nicht umgekehrt stur sein stuhl oder
prinzipien treu der grat zwischen
scheint in der union in dieser frage
ziemlich schmal
theo koll in berlin ist es jetzt eine
normale terminverschiebung weil man
einfach noch zeit braucht oder ist es
ein zeichen für den schlechten zustand
der großen koalition
es ist vor allem ein zeichen für den
schlechten zustand dieser großen
koalition und das immer mehr abgeordnete
auch bei der cdu immer weniger bereit
sind auf die spd zuzugehen formal geht
es dabei um die frage wie viele menschen
sollen künftig die grundrente bekommen
und was darf es kosten im
machtpolitischen kern aber geht es um
die zwei möglichen wege für die union
will man der spd bei der grundrente
weiter entgegenkommen um damit olaf
scholz und der spd spitze ein gutes
argument zu liefern
an der groko festzuhalten oder und das
ist die andere meinung in der union ist
man schon viel zu viele kompromisse
eingegangen und hat der spd schon zu
viel gegeben um am ende zu erleben dass
die sozialdemokraten nach ihrem dezember
parteitag aus der regierung aussteigen
der kampf um die grundrente ist auch ein
strategischer um die zukunft der gruppe
vielen dank für diese einschätzung theo
koll war das ausbremsen
es geht glücklicherweise allen gut auch
den fünf kindern so hieß es heute im
hafen von tarent in süditalien nach
tagelanger odyssee konnte das deutsche
rettungsschiff alle die dort anlegen mit
88 aus dem meer geretteten flüchtlingen
sie werden jetzt auf mehrere länder in
europa verteilt annette hilsenbeck heute
morgen im hafen von tarent im süden
italiens
das rettungsschiff alan kurdi der
deutschen organisation sky läuft ein und
eine woche hatten die 88 migranten an
bord bei schlechtem wetter auf
stürmischer see ausharren müssen
die menschen haben nicht viel kraft wir
haben hier menschen mit alten
schussverletzungen und wir sehen spuren
von folter
die in den libyschen lagern entstanden
sind die helfer hatten das defekte
schlauchboot vor der libyschen küste
entdeckt als sie die menschen retten
wollten wurden sie von schnellbooten der
libyschen küstenwache angegriffen
die italienische regierung hat die
einfahrt jetzt gestattet weil mehrere eu
länder einen teil der migranten
aufnehmen wollen unter anderem
deutschland und frankreich die
verteilung erfolgt nach dem schlüssel
der eu-innenminister vor kurzem auf
malta vereinbart hatten
ich würde nicht sagen dass das einfach
gelaufen ist aber besser als in den
vergangenen zwölf monaten ja also man
merkt schon dass italien jetzt im etwas
anderen kurs einschlägt uns nicht mehr
offen attackiert
italiens neue innenministerin luciana la
motte hatte die vereinbarung von malta
mitgezeichnet sie berichtet diese woche
von einem rückgang der ankünfte bisher
seien es in diesem jahr rund 9600
migranten in 2018 waren es insgesamt
22.000 heute mittag kam erneut
flüchtlinge in italien an
diesmal an bord eines italienischen
versorgungsschiffes wir bleiben beim
thema flüchtlinge und schauen auf die
situation in deutschland hier rechnet
das bundesamt für migration und
flüchtlinge in diesem jahr mit einem
weiteren rückgang der erstanträge auf
asyl auf rund 145.000 die zahlen nannte
bank chef sommer in der bild am sonntag
im vergangenen jahr gab es rund 160.000
erstanträge sommer zufolge wird etwa ein
drittel aller asylanträge anerkannt nach
zwickau dem ort in denen das neonazi
trio nsu jahrelang unerkannt gelebt
hatte heute wurde dort ein mahnmal für
die opfer eingeweiht
eine vorherige gedenkstätte hatten
unbekannte zerstört
das neue denkmal besteht aus zehn bäumen
für jedes opfer einen die polizei
bewacht sie rund um die uhr
unruhe gab es wegen eines kranzes den
die afg niedergelegt hatte eine
linksgerichtete demonstranten
beschädigte ihn es kam zu rangeleien mit
der polizei
herbststurm amélie verfügt derzeit über
westeuropa mit windgeschwindigkeiten von
bis zu 160 kilometern pro stunde traf er
die französische atlantikküste rund
140.000 haushalte waren zeitweise ohne
strom
mehrere personen wurden durch
umstürzende bäume oder herabfallende
äste verletzt viele straßen waren
blockiert an einigen orten gab es
überschwemmungen
und nun zum sport und dia norbert und ja
und da haben die damen ihr olympia
ticket gelöst gestern im qualifikations
hinspiel nur ein mageres 2 0 gegen die
tage heute ein souveränes 70
ja und die herren sind ebenso in tokio
dabei nachdem sie am nachmittag auch das
rückspiel gegen österreich gewann das
allerdings deutlich schwerfälliger als
erwartet nach dem klaren 15 0 gestern
ließen es die deutschen hockey-männer
heute etwas gemächlicher angehen
der gegner aus österreich lange zeit auf
augenhöhe 3 zu 3 stand es bis zum
letzten viertel ehe die deutschen im
dauerregen von mönchengladbach doch noch
für den standesgemäßen erfolg sorgte
niklas wellen mit schöner einzelleistung
zum späten hierzu drei und christopher
rühr nach strafecke zum 5 zu 3
endergebnis
auf die beiden deutschen hockeyteams ist
also weiter verlass bis auf die volks
spiele von moskau 1980 waren die
deutschen mannschaften immer bei den
olympischen spielen vertreten
bundesliga zweitligist hannover hat sich
von seinem glücklosen trainer mirko
slomka getrennt nach nur 125 tagen in
seiner zweiten amtszeit bei den 96ern
ein nachfolger für den 52 jährigen steht
noch nicht fest
im ersten sonntagsspiel der ersten liga
hat düsseldorf den ersten fc köln mit 2
0 besiegt die tore im rheinderby
schossen die fortunen rouwen hennings
und eric tommy die fan-ausschreitungen
ersten berlin derby gestern abend
zwischen union und hertha mit drei
verletzten abend folgen 25
strafverfahren wurden bislang
eingeleitet anhänger beider vereine
hatten pyrotechnik entzündet hertha fans
sollen gezielt zuschauer und spieler mit
leuchtraketen beschossen haben
schiedsrichter aytekin hatte das spiel
für fünf minuten unterbrochen
nach apfel stürmten vermummte um uns
fans auf feld wurden aber von
union-spieler und der
dfb-kontrollausschuss hat angekündigt
ein ermittlungsverfahren gegen beide
klubs einzuleiten das wetter macht auch
nicht wirklich freude die neue woche
beginnt wechselnd oder stark bewölkt
dabei regnet es am vormittag vor allem
im nordosten am nachmittag im südwesten
die höchsttemperatur liegt zwischen 10
und 15 grad und die kommenden tage
bleiben wechselhaft und es wird etwas
kühler
im heute journal um viertel vor zehn
begrüßt 7 marietta slomka wir
verabschieden uns wünschen ihnen noch
einen sehr schönen abend und empfehlen
jetzt theo koll und berlin direkt